WHAT ELSE IS JEFF ZUCKER
DOING?
GOOD QUESTION.
MAYBE WE COULD USE A
CONGRESSIONAL HEARING OR TWO
TO FIND OUT.
>> Tucker: WELL, AN UPDATE
NOW ON THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
HE WASN'T WILLING TO RUN
AGAINST TRUMP IN 2016, NOW
HE SAYS HE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
FACE THE PRESIDENT IN THE
RING DURING THE APPEARANCE
UNIVERSITY OF MIAMI BIDEN
SAID HE WOULD BE ABLE TO
BEAT UP TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> WHEN A GUY ENDED UP
BECOMING OUR NATIONAL LEADER
SAYS I CAN GRAB A WOMAN
ANYWHERE AND SHE LIKES IT
THEY ASKED ME WHY LIKE TO
DEBATE THIS GENTLEMAN I SAID
NO, IF WE WERE IN HIGH
SCHOOL I WOULD TAKE HIM
BEHIND THE GYM AND BEAT THE
HELL OUT OF HIM.
I HAVE BEEN IN A LOT OF
LOCKER ROOMS MY WHOLE LIVE
AND PRETTY GOOD ATHLETE.
ANYBODY WHO TALKED THAT WAY
WAS USUALLY THE FATTEST SOB
IN THE ROOM.
>> Tucker: TOUGH MAN THAT
JOE BIDEN.
TRUMP TWEETED THIS IN
RESPONSE.
CRAZY JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO
ACT LIKE A TOUGH GUY IS HE
WEAK MENTALLY AND
PHYSICALLY.
IF HE THREATENS ME FOR THE
SECOND TIME WITH PHYSICAL
ASSAULT.
HE DOESN'T KNOW ME, BUT HE
WOULD GO DOWN FAST AND HARD.
CRYING ALL THE WAY.
DON'T THREATEN PEOPLE, JOE.
PRESIDENT TWEETED.
THIS MARK STEYN, A
CONNOISSEUR OF.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
YOUR JOB IS TO CALL THIS
FIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> I THINK ON BALANCE, I
PROBABLY GIVE IT TO TRUMP.
ALTHOUGH JOE BIDEN IS NOT TO
BE UNDERESTIMATED.
I UNDERSTAND THAT HE SWIMS
NAKED IN FRONT OF HIS FEMALE
SECRET SERVICE AGENTS MOST
MORNINGS.
WHICH IS NOT SOMETHING MANY
75-YEAR-OLD MEN, OTHER THAN
CHARLIE ROSE OVER AT PBS
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO.
SO HE IS OBVIOUSLY FAIRLY
CONFIDENT OF HIS PHYSIQUE.
I DON'T ACTUALLY UNDERSTAND
WHY HE SAID IF I WAS STILL
IN HIGH SCHOOL I WOULD BEAT
HIM UP BECAUSE TO MY
UNDERSTANDING OF THESE
THINGS, TUCKER, IF YOU ARE
DEFENDING A LADY'S HONOR,
ISN'T GENERALLY SOMETHING
ONE ASSOCIATES WITH HIGH
SCHOOL, IT'S SOMETHING WOULD
DO AFTER HIGH SCHOOL.
AS A GROWN MAN.
SO I AM ACTUALLY IN FAVOR OF
PHYSICAL VIOLENCE BETWEEN
INDIVIDUALS.
I'M IN FAVOR OF DUELING AS
AN ALTERNATIVE.
I'M BEING SERIOUS.
I HAVE BEEN STUCK IN SOME
STUPID LIBEL SUIT IN THE
DISTRICT OF COLUMBIA SIX